in A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones the stark family have ruled the
north for thousands of years those kings
of winter than his wardens of the north
after Aegon came things change in the
first book and season of Thrones when
the Lord of Winterfell Ned Stark is
imprisoned and executed by King Joffrey
Ned son Robb marches South with an army
and the North secedes from the Seven
Kingdoms declaring Rob King in the north
and the Riverlands the first stark King
in three hundred years but this doesn't
last long
Winterfell is captured by Theon Greyjoy
been burned by Ramsay Bolton and the
stark kid scatter Rob's campaign falters
and he's killed the red wedding but the
Bolton's in the phrase Roose Bolton is
made warden of the north so for the
first time in thousands of years the
North is no longer ruled by a stock is
this the end for the kings of winter or
does the north remember in season six of
the Game of Thrones show the stalks make
a quick comeback John and Sansa take
Winterfell from the Bolton's John is
named King and the North is again ruled
by a stock or a snow or a Targaryen or
it's sand depending on who's keeping
score but the point is in the books none
of this has happened by dances and John
is still dead Sansa's still in the Vale
Eyre is still in Braavos bran is still a
tree recons apparently on the island of
ska goes and Stannis Baratheon is still
alive with his army marching against the
Bolton's in Winterfell while Stannis has
some of the north on each side most
houses officially support the Bolton's
and their allies the phrase but unlike
the straightforward story of the show
the books lay out a massively complex
political situation in the north with
dozens of important players each with
their own motivations ambitions
loyalties secrets loves and hates and
hopes fans have written hundreds of
thousands of words of analysis and
theories and predictions on this many
claiming that most of the northern
houses are secretly plotting to assert
the Bolton's and restore a stark to
Winterfell this idea is called the grand
northern conspiracy the Lords of the
north have a lot of good reasons to
support the Starks over the Bolton's
stocks have ruled the north for
thousands of years and people seem to
think they've done a pretty good job
historically they have defended the
north from Raiders slavers Andals walks
and wildlings and it supposedly was a
stock who built the wall to protect the
north from White Walkers
more recently Ned Stark in particular
was renowned for a sense of honour and
justice when in great respect and
loyalty from many people in the North
Barbary Dustin says the Northman loved
the stocks but the Bolton's not so much
the Bolton's are infamous for fleeing
their enemies and wearing their skins as
cloaks their Lord Roose is cruel cold
and creepy known for his habit of
leeching and his son Ramsay is a
straight-up psycho a murderous beast in
human skin who hunts and rapes women for
sport
the Bolton's commit terrible crimes
against the north in order to take
control Ramsay betrays and killed
Northman at Winterfell and kills the
Lady of hornwood loose ends Northern
armies - a suicide mission at dusk and
Dale and at the red wedding the Bolton's
betray King Robb participating in the
breaking of guests ride and the
slaughter of hundreds of Northman every
Lord at Winterfell lost family at the
red wedding and the north were members
so the northern Lords have plenty of
motivation to oppose the Bolton's and
restore the Starks to power what
evidence is there of a conspiracy we
know for a fact that Lord Wyman of house
Mandalay is plotting against the
Bolton's and phrase he pretends to be on
their side but in dance he secretly
meets with Davos Seaworth and gives an
awesome speech about the debt of Amanda
Lee's owed to the Starks and about the
murder of Wyman son Wendell at the red
wedding
he says the North remembers and mummys
fast is almost done Wyman reveals with
the help of an iron Bond boy called wax
Wyman's learned the truth of the sack of
Winterfell that it wasn't Theon Greyjoy
but Ramsay Bolton who burned the castle
and killed its people and the bran and
Rickon Stark weren't killed by sea on
but as still alive apparently Rickon is
on ska goes an island up near the wall
Wyman tailed Devils to go there and
fetch recon so the north can rally
around the young stark and opposed the
Bolton's
if Devils does this Wyman says he'll
accept Stannis as his king with Rickon
stark as Lord of Winterfell that seems
to be the plan
so mandala is plotting against the
Bolton's and other houses are in honor
to Robert Glover is at the meeting with
Davos and he may be in touch with his
brother Lord Gilbert there even hints
that Robert may raise an army Wyman says
houses Locke and Flint of widow's watch
follow his lead and we do see someone
from house Locke speak up against Ramsey
so it seems houses lock Flint and Glover
are to at least some extent a part of
Mandela's conspiracy it's also possible
that house umber is involved the umbers
appear to be split down the middle half
of them under crowfoot on the side with
Stannis while the other half under horse
Bay number side with the Bolton's but
it's made clear that horse Bain isn't
really loyal to Roose he only joins the
Bolton's because the phrase hold his
nephew the great John captive Roose says
the umbers are cunning and that he fears
them and he probably should his back in
clash the umbers are ordered to work
with the manderlys to build a fleet of
warships and in dance we see the fleet
complete hidden up the white knife river
so given that we know the numbers have
been working on a secret police with the
mandalas and that they're not really
loyal to the Bolton's
it seems very plausible to the umbers
are in on Wyman's conspiracy there's
further evidence for this in the dance
chapters in Winterfell where all the
Bolton's and phrase and their supposed
northern allies are cooped up together
in the castle with snowstorms and
Stannis coming outside while tensions
slowly rise there's this one bit where
it's mentioned that someone makes
snowmen shaped like four particular
northern Lords Wyman Manderly [ __ ]
Bane amber Harwood stout and Barbary
Dustin there's pretty strong evidence
that these four snowmen represent a
conspiracy in Winterfell
at one point we see Harwood stout is the
Swan man of Barbary Dustin talking
quietly with [ __ ] a number who we know
has been working with Wyman after this
conversation Barbour becomes strangely
interested in the Winterfell crypts and
gets Theon to take her down there the
crypts of the ancient resting place of
dead Starks each represented by a statue
holding a sword Barberie notices that
three of these swords are missing the
significance of this is that these three
missing swords are the swords taken by
OSHA Amira and bran when they
Cape Winterfell these three missing
swords prove waxes story that bran and
Rickon are alive and that the Bolton's
lie about the sack of Winterfell the
fact that Bob researches the crypts in
the first place suggests that she heard
waxes story from Wyman possibly through
the conversation Harwood has with [ __ ]
Bane further we know from one Java that
Wyman uses long visits to the privy to
disguise secret meetings and it's hinted
he continues to do this at Winterfell so
the evidence is pretty strong that Wyman
Harwood Barberie and horse Bane are
conspiring in Winterfell discussing wax
a story about bran and Rickon and
Mandela's plans to restore House Stark
after Barbara visits the cribs she
speaks out boldly to the phrase about
the people killed at the red wedding she
parks her lips in a thin feral smile and
says the North remembers so that's one
part of the granddaughter conspiracy
Wyman Manderly Robert Glover horse Bane
amber and Barbara Dustin along with the
locks and Flint's appear to be plotting
to betray the Bolton's and make Rickon
Stark Lord of Winterfell but there's a
whole other part of the conspiracy which
takes place to the south with its roots
in events of the past in the second book
Robb Stark says that if he dies he wants
Jon Snow to follow him as king in the
north
at this point Sansa is married to Tyrion
Lannister and Robb believes iya bran and
Rickon to be dead so he decided the best
course of action is to legitimize Jon as
a stock and have him follow Robb as king
if he dies
later that chapter Robb meets with some
of his laws and gets him to sign a
document to declare Jon his heir now
that Robb is dead the question is who
knows about this will and what plans
might be underway to carry it out and
make John King the people who are
present at the signing of the will
include Catelyn Stark
Edna a Tully Greatjon umber Jason Master
major Mormont and galbart Glover the
great John and Jason are both prisoners
so they probably can't do much but mage
and galbart are sent on a mission to
Howland Reed in the neck and it seems as
though they do arrive because the
crannogmen follow up on some orders Rob
gives about moat Cailin
so mage and gal that seemed to be with
Howland in the neck and this offers a
lot of opportunities for scheming
because not only a mage and gal but some
of the only people in Westeros who know
that Jon Snow is the rightful king in
the north
but Howland Reed is the only living
survivor of the fight at the Tower of
joy years ago where it was discovered
that John is the son of Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen potentially giving
John a claim on the Iron Throne of all
Westeros that is a lot of super
important information in one place and
there are some hints that this
information is being put into action
this involves another witness to Rob's
will Catelyn Stark
so Catelyn dies at the red wedding but
in the book she is resurrected by beric
Dondarrion and becomes Lady Stoneheart a
terrible vengeful spirit who leads the
Brotherhood without banners down a dark
and murderous path killing everyone even
remotely connected to the red wedding
but stones how it's not just a brutal
killer there's a definite method to a
murder during the siege of Riverrun a
singer called tom of seven streams spies
for the Brotherhood in the Lannister
Frey camp he lets the Brotherhood know
when certain phrase are travelling the
Riverlands so that Lady Stoneheart can
capture and kill them Tom may also hear
about the transport of Lannister
prisoners and an upcoming Lannister
wedding some fans speculated the
Brotherhood and some river Lords will
free the prisoners and crash the wedding
to massacre phrase and Lannisters and a
red wedding 2.0 but Stonehouse
activities also connect back to Rob's
will because then faced stone heart
travels in or near hags mire the place
where Rob's will is signed then heads
back up into the neck the same place
Howland mage and galbart seem to be it
seems likely that stone heart is
involved in a plot with these guys over
Rob's will because she's not only a
witness to the will like mage and
galbart but Stoneheart also has Rob's
old crown so the power to crown the next
king in the north is in her hands which
does raise an issue stone heart might
not want to crown John as king because
at least in life Catelyn really doesn't
like John as a bastard son of Ned John
represents Ned's infidelity to cat but
it just so happens that Howland Reed is
the one person in the world who can tell
Catelyn that Jon isn't really Ned's
bastard that he's Lee Ana's sung by
Rhaegar Targaryen
Ned claims John was his in order to
protect him so stone heart is a bit of
an angry motor Sambi at the moment and
might not listen but if Howland can
change Stone hearts mind about John she
may be happy to join in on a conspiracy
to crown John King in the north
LEM says that stone heart doesn't speak
because a throat is cut too deep but he
says she remembers another witness to
Rob's will is Admiral a Tully he's a
prisoner of the phrase at Riverrun but
he meets with some important people in
one chapter Jamie leaves him alone with
Thomas Evans the Brotherhood spy so it's
possible Edie shared information with
the Brotherhood and stone heart later
Jamie lets Edna and to Riverrun to end
the siege which presents a golden
opportunity to conspire with the Tully
men including ed Mia's uncle Brendan
blackfish Brendan is loyal to how stock
and Jamie says he doesn't doubt Brendan
will continue the fight in the show
Brendan dies in Riverrun but in the
books
Edna helps him escape so now Brendan's
out there somewhere determined to fight
for House Stark and since he speaks with
his nephew Edna he may now know about
Rob's will and the possible plot to
crown John snow another couple of men
who leave Riverrun include Desmond Grell
and Robin Rhaegar the Tully
master-at-arms and captain of God these
guys choose to join the Nights Watch at
the wall where John happens to be fans
speculate that these trusted Tully men
may have been sent by Ed Muir in order
to contact John maybe to tell him about
the conspiracy to crown John as heir to
Rob so this ripple and stuff is not as
certain as the mandala conspiracy
there's no direct evidence that any of
these guys are plotting over Rob's will
but it is at least very suspicious that
mage and galbart witnesses to Rob's will
and stone heart who has Rob's crown all
go to the neck where Howland lives the
one guy who knows the truth of John's
birth the stuff with Ed Muir Brendan
Desmond and Robin might not be related
but it is plausible that these guys are
also somehow involved in a conspiracy to
crown John Snow okay so we've got some
Manderley conspiracy around Winterfell
to betray the
opens and support Rickon Stark and a
possible conspiracy in the neck to crown
Jon Snow as rods heir to the north
there's also possibly some plotting
going on within the army that Stannis is
marching on Winterfell part of Stannis's
army is made up of men he brought up
from the south but most of them are
Northman including the mountain Klansmen
some more monsters and others and the
Northman don't like Stannis he's a
stranger to the north and worships of
foreign God the real reason they march
in his army is to kill Bolton's and
rescue is stark in the books Ramsay
marries a girl who the Bolton's say is
aya Stark but is actually a girl called
Jane Poole the real I err is over in
Braavos but the North doesn't know that
far as they're concerned Ned Stark's
little girl was in the clutches of
Bolton's bastard and they're willing to
die to rescue her these guys are
passionately loyal to House Stark so is
it possible that they're involved in
these conspiracies to install recon or
crown John the best hint we've got is
that two leaders of the mountain
Klansmen the nori and the Flint come and
visit John at the wall and John himself
thinks that they must have some special
reason to be their fan suggests that
these Klansmen know about Rob's will and
come to the wall to judge if John could
be a worthy King in the north
John discusses his plans for the
wildlings with the Klansmen and tells
them he may seem a green boy in their
eyes but he is still a son of Eddard
Stark which may be exactly what the
Klansmen want to hear but if the
Klansmen in on the plot to crown John
how are they in contact with the folks
in the neck who know about the will one
possibility is that they're in touch
with mage Mormont through her daughter
Alassane who's on the march with Stannis
mages other daughter leiana is the kid
who writes that awesome letter and that
speech in the show alternatively the
Clemson might be in touch with galbart
Glover maybe through his sister-in-law
Sybil who's been spending a suspiciously
large amount of time praying in the
godswood which is something Sansa does
in Clash to receive secret messages so
the Klansmen might possibly know about
Rob's will but there is another
complication in that the Klansmen know
that bran Stark is alive they see him
traveling north to the war
under Klansmen from house little even
meets brown this is important
information because bran is King Bob's
oldest living brother his heir if it
weren't for the will which only skips
Brantford John because Rob thought that
bran is dead it's very telling that the
Klansmen don't tell Stan us about bran
whatever their intentions they're
clearly keeping secrets so while there's
no clear evidence of any conspiracy
among the Northman in Stannis's army
there are some possible connections and
at the least the Northmen are clearly
more loyal to Stark
than they are to Stannis there are few
other northern houses to talk about how
scarf dark is an interesting one because
on off cough dark joins with Stannis but
secretly plans to betray him for the
Bolton's part of his scheme is to
forcibly marry the heir to karhold
Ella's calf talked to his son Creegan so
he can beam Lord of karhold but Aleph
escapes and the person she turns to for
protection and justice is none other
than Jon Snow she comes all the way
north to the wall and begs him for help
layers him as her only hope at the last
son of a dad stock there's no evidence
Elif knows about any conspiracy but her
attitude to John does support the idea
that the people in the north see John as
the inheritor of Ned Stark's legacy and
a legitimate leader in the north anyway
in a sample chapter of when Stannis
finds out about our nafse deception and
locks up his men so the Karstarks are
out of action for now there's also house
hornwood after the depths of Lord
Hallows and darin Danella becomes the
lady of the hornwood but ramsay forcibly
marries and kills her starving her in a
dungeon until she chews her and fingers
off ramsay now calls himself lord of the
horn wood and some horn wood men have
submitted to him joining the Bolton army
but as barbara dustin points out the
horn woods haven't forgotten what ramsay
did to denilla
there's no evidence of horn woods
involved in any conspiracy but it's fair
to say they're not real loyal to the
Bolton's the Cohens and tall hearts are
similar we don't know all that much
about them but we do know that rusyns
Kerwin and tall hot men into a suicide
mission at dusk and ale and that at the
sack of Winterfell Ramsay betrays and
kills Lord clay Cohen and Leah Bulls
toheart
some survivors of this battle
joining Stannis's army which could be a
really big deal these men could spread
the word around these crimes and
betrayal at Winterfell which most of the
north still believes were committed by
Theon so while we don't know of any
color not all art involvement in any
conspiracy the houses are in Roose
Bolton's words not to be relied on
really the only big northern house that
probably is loyal to house Bolton is
house or is well the res walls are tied
to the Bolton's by marriage and we sear
is well leaders working closely with the
Bolton's and phrase the res both did
lose men at the red wedding but there
are no particular hens that are disloyal
to the Bolton's so in the words of Roose
Bolton northern politics in dance is a
world of treachery and deceit people
fighting with the Bolton's aren't really
loyal to the Bolton's people fighting
with Stannis son really loyal to Stannis
most folks seem to want a stark in
Winterfell
but is there a grand northern conspiracy
we do know Wyman Manderly is plotting to
install Rickon stark Robert Glover the
Flynn's and locks are in honored and
probably so others snowmen in Winterfell
[ __ ] Bane and Barbary to the south as
a probable plot of the Rob's will to
crown John's involving mage and Galvez
and Howland who are connected to stone
heart and Tom and Ed Muir and Brendan
and the Riverrun guys it's also kind of
possible that the mountain clans I will
say Mormont or Sybil Glover are involved
themselves connected to Jon are all
these people working together in unison
secretly scheming to play Stannis and
Roose against each other to get
vengeance on the Bolton's and frays and
finally to return a stark to Winterfell
in a truly grand northern conspiracy are
all these people connected maybe but
probably not for a few reasons firstly
they don't have phones in Westeros so
it's really hard to communicate secretly
there are messenger ravens but we're
told a bunch of times that it's a bad
idea to trust a secret to a bird they
can be intercepted or lost and besides
letters are generally read and written
by maesters who themselves aren't
trusted Barbara and Wyman specifically
both questioned maesters so
communications card and secondly the
bigger a conspiracy is the less likely
it is to stay secret that's true in the
real world and in Westeros and we go to
Westeros
sample in the Karstark treachery as far
as we know only a few caustic mint know
about our nafs plan to betray status and
yet thanks to alice the truth gets out
Stannis himself makes a point that you
can't keep secrets among lots and lots
of people beat ground conspiracies just
aren't that plausible what it really
looks like is that there are multiple
different separate plans that work here
mandala wants to make Rick on Lord of
Winterfell
recognizing Stannis as king while mage
and Goldberg presumably want to make Jon
Snow King people like Stone hearten the
mountain Klansmen have their own
priorities these all seem like separate
plots so the evidence doesn't support
the idea of one big cohesive grand
northern conspiracy what it does support
of several medium-sized loosely
overlapping plots in the north and river
lands which doesn't have as much of a
ring to it but still ultimately we can
conclude that yes there are conspiracies
at work in the north
the North remembers millennia of just
stop rule the North remembers Boulton
crimes of the red wedding and elsewhere
the manderlys remember the Riverlands
remember the neck remembers Winterfell
remembers the Klansmen remember and buy
one plot or another the Starks will rule
the North again thanks for watching
there are lots more complications that
we didn't cover here like the role of
Sansa and Littlefinger the Skaar go see
Mance Rayder and the wildlings the pink
letter and the hooded man the location
of the document signed as Rob's will and
of course the White Walkers and the army
of the Dead will there even be a North
left to rule we'll talk about some of
this stuff in future videos thank you to
the Game of Thrones fan expert to help
with this video script including lady
Gwyn and yoke boy of radio Westeros and
Nina Friel of the good Queen Alassane
tumblr links are below the ground
northern conspiracy is an idea that
hundreds of fans have contributed to
over the years in particular you might
like to check out essays by ye'd and
brand wrath and can choose thanks also
to artists amok and Zippo five one four
and attached alternates for permission
to use their work lots of links in the
description finally thank you to the
patron supporting ol G of X this vide
go truly would not exist without your
support thanks for your patience on this
one it was a long time coming we'll be
holding a vote soon on the topic over
the next big video so make sure to make
your voice heard again thank you all and
see you next time